to the minister for women and the
qualities Sean
tackling violence against women and
girls is a very
very priority we're supporting The
Honorable member for Tunbridge Wells
protection from sex-based harassment in
public bill which would make public
sexual harassment a specific offense we
also provided over 160 000 pounds of
funding last year to the National
stalking helpline run by the Susie lamp
blue trust who I've met and have
responded to 700 7440 calls and emails
from all relating to victims of stalking
between April and last year and March
this year oddson I thank the minister
for that answer and as she will know 71
of women have experienced harassment in
public spaces yet too many people
continue to accept these patterns of
violence or harassment or they don't
have the confidence or resources to
confront this Behavior when they see it
the northumbria PCC Kim McGinnis has
recently launched a fantastic Initiative
for active bystander training to prevent
assault and the behaviors which lead to
it what will the government do to
encourage similar positive action to
tackle the root of misogyny in other
places across the country
The Honorable lady is right to highlight
the work of the north tamborine police
crime Police Commissioner 3.6 million
pounds was given for the safest streets
funding and the safety of women at night
fund one thing that was very important
was I was surprised to read that one in
six adults that's not only women and
girls that's also men and boys have
actually been stalked that surrendous
and it's just this sort of project that
the government are funding through this
substantial million pounds funding that
they're providing in this area just like
committee Carolina thank you Mr Speaker
violence and harassment of women and
girls doesn't just take place in this
country it happens across the globe
particularly in places like Iran and
Afghanistan can I ask my honorable
friend what work is going on across
government to make sure that the UK is
not a bystander when it comes to Global
violence against girls and particularly
what are we doing about the prescription
of the irgc in Iran
minister of course the right honorable
lady knows that this is the province of
the foreign Commonwealth development
office they lead the government's
support for human rights but also
particularly for matters pertaining to
women
um this government however working with
the home office the fcdo do a lot of
work to promote women's rights it's
really important that the political
systems in other countries are able to
protect those rights and the main thing
we do is sanctions sanctions are very
important to um in this area they send a
clear message to all sorts of political
organizations across the world including
the Iranian authorities they will be
held to account for the repression of
women abroad yes
thank you Mr Speaker last year nearly 5
000 cases of spiking incidents were
reported to the police in England and
Wales but this figure is likely to be
much higher
spiking is endemic in our nighttime
economy
women and girls should be able to go
about their business and enjoy night
South without fear
while the government paid lip service
cases across the country are rising yet
we have no actual reporting system for
this hideous crime when will the
minister do the right thing by victims
and make spiking a separate criminal
offense
the government is looking very carefully
and speaking to stakeholders about
spiking it's quite clear that there are
at the moment adequate criminal offenses
for this sort of behavior and there are
quite high profile um convictions that
we get however the honorable lady is
quite right to highlight this and the
government will look at it and review it
there are specific funds that have been
given there are better testing evidence
is really really important but what we
need to do is to get women and boys to
come forward when they have been spiked
and it also affects older people I read
a case the other day where there was
somebody in his 40s who was spiked so
it's absolutely essential that we work
in this area
it's Mr Speaker
yeah okay
I took my glasses off but that's always
a problem isn't it
um the case review made for a very
sobering reading
um around the allegations of racism
misogyny and homophobia in the myth
they're deeply disturbing the Home
Secretary and the Prime Minister have
been very clear that urgent improvements
must be delivered we will have
confidence uh I have confidence that the
Met commissioner is leading in this area
I've also met Damelin Owens and she's
doing great work in this area we want to
see Improvement and we must have it
perhaps Federation now accepting
institutional racism plus the vile
sexism detailed by Casey and damning
fire brigade reports will the government
now order an urgent inquiry into
cultures among uniformed officers to
keep both workplaces and the public safe
yeah when they start
workplaces and the public must be safe
but I do have confidence that work is
now going on particularly in the met but
across the whole country racism will not
be accepted particularly in the Met
unfortunately the mayor has carried his
got his eye off the ball in that under
him crime including issues of racism
Rose by 10 labor are actually weak on
crime it is this government that is
holding them back to account Patricia
Gibson
with your permission Mr Speaker I will
answer questions three and twelve
together the gender pay Gap has fallen
by approximately a quarter in the last
decade the conservative government
introduced gender peer Gap reporting
building on the pay protections we
already have in the equality act and
this has motivated employers to look at
their pay data and improve workplace
gender equality Trisha Gibson Mr Speaker
the gender makeup feeds the pension gap
which impacts on a larger proportion of
the women in the UK the government
doesn't even have a suitable definition
for the gender pension Gap as a
campaigner on this issue for many years
does the minister agree with me that
delays in reducing the gender pension
are simply unacceptable and can she tell
me what representations she has made to
her colleagues in the DWP to urgently
address this yeah Mr Speaker the gender
pensions Gap as The Honorable lady who
describes it is a complex issue it is
tied to the labor market the pension
system and demographic differences but
what we've been doing means that by 2030
over 3 million women will have benefited
from a higher state pension due to the
new state pension reforms on average
female pensioners will receive around
570 pounds a year more than they would
have received under the previous system
and that is the work that we're doing to
address this issue
you must speak our foster Society
evidence shows that over one third of
women want to work are prevented by
reasons including a lack of flexible
working options and affordable child
care the UK government was reformed to
their consultation still requires
employees to request flexible working
while the minister ensure that less is
provided as a day one right to support
women to remain at work and to help
tackle the gender we get here here
Mr Speaker The Honorable lady will know
that we are supporting the employment
relations flexible working private
members bill which will deliver changes
including that employers will be able to
will be required to consult with an
employee as a means of exploring
alternative options before rejecting a
request for reflexible working and
employees will be unable to make two
flexible working requests a year up from
one and will receive faster decisions on
their requests employees will no longer
be required to explain the impact of the
requested Arrangement on the employer
and we think that that will go a long
way to resolve the issues around
flexible working Joe
is the highlighting the twin impact of
the gender pay Gap and the cost of
living crisis on women what support is
my right-honorable friend giving to
women who are struggling financially
I think the honorable lady thought her
question she will know that the support
we provide is based on need not by
protected characteristic so the decisive
action we have taken has been to support
households across the UK whilst
remaining fiscally responsible we are
delivering the largest ever increase in
the National living wage benefiting over
2 million people and that is
disproportionately women and we're also
prioritizing support for the most
vulnerable families increasing benefits
in line with inflation and that means
more than 10 million working age
families will see an increase in their
benefit payments we don't come to smps
person Oswald
speaker according to the Foster Society
lags behind other European countries in
making companies act to close the gender
P Gap and it has failed to introduce
mandatory reporting of P differences
based on ethnicity if the UK government
is serious about driving down pay
inequality why won't they require
employers to set out action plans to
improve gender equality and why won't
the Mandy intersectional ethnicity pay
Gap reporting and if they're not serious
and they continue to refuse to act will
they devolve employment law to Scotland
so that we can do it ourselves
Mr Speaker
um on the issue of mandatory ethnicity
reporting I have said it in almost every
uh equality rules I'm prepared to say it
again it is not the appropriate tool
ethnicity pay Gap reporting cannot be
compared to gender pay Gap reporting
gender pay Gap reporting is binary
ethnicity pay-up quoting goes across at
least 19 groups it is it is dependent on
geography among other things as well as
representation within the workforce we
need to do what we can to make sure that
employers do the right thing but these
sorts of interventionist policies that
The Honorable lady is Raising are not
helpful and they actually make things
worse obscure the data and do absolutely
nothing as she's describing in order to
address issues around ethnicity pay Gap
reporting Angela Richards for please sir
minister
thank you Mr Speaker the equality Act of
2010 covers a number of protected
characteristics including age disability
gender reassignment marriage and civil
Partnerships race religion and belief
sex and sexual orientation and my right
humble friend has written to the ehrc to
understand if the ACT sufficiently is
clear in the balance it strikes between
the interests of people with those
different characteristics Richards thank
the minister for his answer what
assessment has he made on the importance
of protecting Single Sex spaces
sister I thank my honorable Femme for
her question and we are committed to
maintaining the safeguard that allows
organizations to provide Single Sex
spaces it is important that the
principle of being able to operate
spaces is reserved for women and girls
the government is committed to tackling
harassment and abusive Behavior by all
individuals and ensuring that Single Sex
spaces are safe ehrc has published
guidance on legislative on the
legislation and the clarity that is
there to help those that are providing
those spaces and this does not change
the legal position or the law
um just this week the government stated
that it agreed with the law commission's
recommendations in its review of hate
crime laws that um they should not be
additional protective characteristics of
sex and gender
can the minister explain what the
implications are for this of moves
towards making misogyny a hate crime of
violence towards women and girls and can
he assured us that there's not any
intention to address protected
characteristics and the equality Act
or
over the last few years there have been
at least I think 15 calls for various
extra characteristics to be added there
hasn't been sufficient evidence uh to to
do that we will always keep those under
review but let me make it very clear
that this government will absolutely do
everything he can to tackle any issues
around violence towards women and girls
we have been strong on our actions on
those that seek to create harm and will
continue to do so
thank you Mr Speaker the equality Act of
2010 places a duty on businesses and
service providers to make reasonable
adjustments to improve disabled people's
access to the goods and services that
they provide not if it is absolutely
imperative that they are not placed in a
substantial disadvantage compared to
those who are non-disabled
forward I thank the minister for that
answer Maggie from my part of East Devon
is one of 11 million people in this
country who has hearing loss Maggie went
to a well-known High Street branch and
explained that because of her hearing
she's unable to use the phone and she
was offered a 50-mile round trip to
Exeter instead so in pursuit of the
equalities act can the minister explain
what the government is doing to ensure
Banks and big businesses make reasonable
adjustments for those with hearing loss
Minister and well I'm sorry to hear of
the example of The Honorable gentleman
has made about his constituent and under
the equality act it would be indirect
discrimination if a service provider
puts Place rules or procedures which
apply the same way for everyone but have
a disproportionate adverse effect on
particular groups I'd be more than happy
to meet with him to discuss the
particular issue and see if further
action can be devised for his
constituents sir Oliver Hill my uh rise
of wild friend agree with me that this
goes hand in hand with access to work
and does he agree with me that it is
important that those who assess for
grants for access to work shouldn't be
too much the generalist and that they
should have specific knowledge of the
sort of conditions of the person
concerned and I'd be interested to know
if he has any plans to explain you know
how this might be improved because I
have had one or two complaints finished
up so I can say to my advice on my
friend that the disability minister is
actually looking at this as we speak
seeking to see how this can be
streamlined I'll be more than happy to
update him with further details
Mr speaker
thank you Mr Speaker with permission I
will take question six and nine together
it is this government that has
recognized the maternal disparities do
exist for black Asian and minority
ethnic women and those from economically
disadvantaged backgrounds that is why in
February last year we set up the
maternity disparities task force to
tackle these disparities
thank you Mr Speaker will the minister
um agree with me that we owe a huge
thanks to the member for stretton for
her work as the chair of the appg on
black maternal health and secondly black
women are four times more likely to die
during pregnancy and childbirth and four
to three percent more likely to miscarry
the select committee report highlighted
the government is failing to act with a
maternity disparities task force
ironically meeting every nine months
instead of every two will the minister
commit today to set binding targets and
properly resource solutions to end this
Scandal and these disparities Minister
I'm very happy to place your record my
thanks to the honorable member for
streatham she does a fantastic work in
this place can I just point out the
figures are lower than that it's now
three three and a half times uh for
black women compared to white women it's
still too high and that's why we're
doing record amounts of work in this
space only last month uh the NHS
published the three-year single delivery
plan for maternity and neonative
services which will end disparities or
trying to end disparities in pregnancy
and uh childbirth and it's why the the
task force itself is looking at
preconception care where many of these
disparities are embedded years before a
woman gets pregnant
you Mr Speaker whether it's three and a
half times more likely
that black women die in childbirth or
four times more likely it is a shameful
and inexcusable reality but that is the
case in our country the women inequality
select committee was absolutely clear
about the government's own failings in
this area it criticized a lack of
accurate data a lack of funding for
maternity Services a lack of consistency
of care across the country a lack of
representation of black women on the
maternal disparities tax task force and
the downplaying of the role of racism in
this issue when is the government going
to get a grip on this disgraceful
Injustice with the urgency that it
demands or can I say that to say that
the maternity disparities task force
doesn't represent black women when the
co-chair is Professor Jacqueline dunkley
Baines one of the renowned uh lead of
midwives in the world a black woman
herself who is leading uh this work she
has been driving forward the work
whether it's on local maternity neonatal
state systems publishing equity and the
quality action plans I'm sure the online
members read her own for her own local
area whether it's the MNC introducing
standards where midwives are expected to
have cultural competency whether it's
the NHS England introducing diverse
Workforce with getting to equity
programs to ensure that inspiring ethnic
minority midwives are promoted or
whether it's the maternal medicines
networks to targeting black mothers in
particular to improve their overall
health during pregnancy there is
significant work being done in this area
it's really disturbing that there are
these serious disparities in maternal
Health outcomes for black women so will
the minister really reassure us that the
government is looking at the causes of
this because until we are clear on
what's causing it we're not going to
solve this problem
is exactly right and that is why the
task force is focusing on preconception
care because before a woman gets
pregnant many of the disparities have
been there for years before and that is
why we're working with stakeholders in
this space to see how we can improve
access to preconception care which will
make a huge difference to the outcomes
of pregnancy and birth
thank you Mr Speaker as chair of the all
party group of baby lost I've heard
evidence of how one of the ways we can
get around this or help women in this
situation is by having continuity of
carer it helps with them exposing
lifestyle choices and uh and and other
experiences such as domestic violence
that might happen with people who are
from anything diverse background or
socially deprived background can the
minister let me know what the department
is doing to help expand a continuity of
carer for people that need it
well absolutely I can reassure my
honorable friend because we're spending
seven million pounds to ensure that 75
of black Asian and minority ethnic women
are being cared for by the same Midwife
during their pregnancy because we do
know that continuity and carer improves
outcomes for those women
we now come to shutter secretary and
these Gods thank you Mr Speaker my
understanding is that the black maternal
mortality Gap is actually 3.7 times more
likely the Asian maternal mortality Gap
is twice as likely than white women we
also find now that women in deprived
areas are two and a half times more
likely to die than those from the least
deprived areas and scandalously even
before the pandemic hit maternal
mortalities increased by 12
in the previous six years of Tory
government now as the minister said the
maternal disparities task force was
supposed to be tackling this can I ask
how many months elapsed between its last
two meetings
finished up well absolutely we recognize
the disparities of existed for decades
and we are the first government ever to
recognize that and to set up the
maternities disparities high schools to
tackle those problems we actually met on
the 18th of April and we've set about
introducing the toolkit that we'll be
looking at preconception care because as
we know that many of these women face
disparities long before they get
pregnant long before they give birth and
it's by tackling those preconception uh
disparities that we all improve outcomes
for those women
thank you Mr Speaker the minister didn't
answer my question I think because she
knows the answer the task force didn't
meet for nine months then it was
suddenly convened the day after a timing
report had been published no government
serious about this would allow enough
time for a baby to be carried to term to
a lapse between meetings nor would it
scrap continuity of carer targets not
mentioned by the minister or amid
serious action against maternity
disparities from its Women's Health
strategy labor would restore maternity
Services training 10 000 midwives and
nurses a year paid for by scrapping the
non-don tax exemption so why is the
government letting women pay the price
for its failures
well this government doesn't need to
have a meeting to take action we are
working night and day to drive these
disparities down 165 million pounds
going into funding maternity Services
overall there's 95 million pounds to pay
for 1 200 more meatwise and another 100
uh consultant Obstetricians
um she will I'm sure has read page to
page the three-year maternity plan she
says she has um I hope she has uh on uh
driving down inequalities in both
maternal and neonatal care and it'd be
great if we could have cross-party
support for this groundbreaking work
we've come to Tropical family question
one sir
[Applause]
secretary thank you Mr Speaker last week
we published a report on the substantial
progress we have made in delivering our
groundbreaking inclusive written action
plan to tackle on Fair ethnic
disparities just one year after we
launched the action plan we fulfilled 32
of the 74 commitments including issuing
voluntary guidance for employers on how
to measure and address ethnicity pay
gaps and I will report back to
Parliament in 12 months time on the
progress we've made in delivering the
remaining actions in building a stronger
fair and more united Society
my right honorable friend for her answer
Mr Speaker while I fully understand the
need for protected places for women and
I totally support this and also issues
when it comes to sports
I'm growing increasingly concerned that
trans people are becoming demonized in
some quarters
what is the Secretary of State doing to
protect the interests and protect the
very nature of genuine trans people
I thank my honorable friend for that
question and I want to emphasize that
the government believes in the principle
of individual liberty and in the
humanity and dignity of every person and
in everything we do we want to make sure
that we take the toxicity out of the
debate a lot of the demonization is
happening out there on social media we
have a responsibility to make sure that
all trans people have that dignity and
are looked after
um in terms of what other things we're
doing NHS England is working to explain
clinical capacity in adult gender
identity Services by establishing new
pilot clinics rooted in primary care and
Sexual Health Services and four of those
new clinics have opened since 2020 with
the fifth doing this year and they will
be able to provide a lot of the health
care that the trans people need
Foundation shows that over 2 million
women in the UK and below the real
living wage and are also more likely to
be trapped and low pay insecure and
precarious jobs so we'll administer what
the cabinet colleagues ensure that what
actually pays by introducing a real
living wage and strengthening protection
for workers and zero art contracts
I I Thank The Honorable gentleman for
for raising this issue in terms of women
being able to progress and do well in
work which is why at the DWP we have a
focus on in work progression giving
particularly women who perhaps had child
care or other needs or training needs
the support they need to progress and
thrive in work
it's Luke Evans Mr Speaker we know that
between half a million and a million
people in the UK are using steroids
particularly to improve their body image
now some studies show that this is even
more prolific in the gay community with
up to six times more than their straight
counterparts so will the department
commission and work with dcms and health
to look into a study of anabolic use in
the UK
Bethesda well Mr Speaker can I commend
my honorable friend for the extensive
work that he's done in this important
area I think I absolutely agree with his
uh analysis and of course as both a dcms
minister and the minister for equalities
I can assure him that I will be taking a
very keen interest in this area of work
Mr Speaker welcome changes have been
made by Mog on transgender prisoners
excluding not just sexual but violent
transgender prisoners from the general
women's estate and also who are still
physically mailed but also accessing
vulnerability for females on the basis
of sex at Birth does the minister accept
the need not just in Justice
institutions but across other
departments for both single sex spaces
and services but also for the acceptance
of sex at Birth there's been the
criteria
but this does thank you Mr Speaker yes
of course safety safety must come first
and while it is true that over 90 of
transgender women are in the male estate
I think it is right that we have further
strengthened our policy to uh to uh as
far as those committed sexual violent
offenses are concerned all those retain
birth genitalia who can only be uh house
elsewhere in truly exceptional
exceptional circumstance review in the
case by case